Accidents will happen.
But once in awhile, they're blessings in disguise.
Take TV show bloopers: sometimes they make
the show funnier, more convincing, or just
more all-around interesting.
These bloopers from popular TV shows were
just so perfect for the plot and characters,
they had to stay in the final cut.
Seinfeld
The best Seinfeld episodes featured the fabulous
foursome struggling with some kind of existential
nightmare.
Perhaps the best example is the 1991 episode
"The Parking Garage," in which the gang spends
the entire story wandering around a parking
complex, unable to find their car until the
very end.
As scripted, the episode was supposed to finish
with some small talk and the group driving
off, their struggle final over.
But when actor Michael Richards put the key
in the ignition, the car wouldn't start — an
unplanned ending that cracked up the cast
and crew.
It's a more fitting and funnier way to wrap
up the story, and it proved just too good
to cut.
Supernatural
A commonly uttered profane phrase doubled
as an catchphrase for paranormal investigator
Dean Winchester on Supernatural.
Actor Jensen Ackles uttered the line as an
off-script addition while making the 2007
episode "Bad Day at Black Rock."
"Son of a bitch!"
His boisterous, hilariously frustrated, over-the-top
delivery did a number on costar Jared Padalecki,
and the inspired improvisation made it into
the final episode.
Friends
Ross Geller was always a man with quirky pursuits—like
playing experimental keyboard music and owning
a monkey, for example.
In the seventh-season Friends episode "The
One With Joey's New Brain," Ross desperately
wants to play the bagpipes at Chandler and
Monica's upcoming wedding…even though they
aren't interested, and despite his complete
inability to actually play the instrument.
During a sneak peek, actress Jennifer Aniston
clearly can't handle it, and does everything
in her power to not break — a real-life
reaction too good to leave on the cutting-room
floor.
How I Met Your Mother
Wayne Brady's first big claim to fame was
as a gifted improvisational comic on ABC's
Whose Line is It Anyway?
In Brady's first episode as Barney's brother
on the sitcom How I Met Your Mother, actor
Neil Patrick Harris made it his mission to
improvise a line that would make Brady crack.
The one that worked?
A reference to a song by Britney Spears' backup
dancer-turned-husband, Kevin Federline.
"What?"
"Cool."
"Popozao."
Brady had to quickly duck away to keep from
cracking up on camera — an awkward bit of
blocking, but the end result was too funny
to cut.
The Brady Bunch
In his 1992 memoir Growing Up Brady, Barry
Williams revealed he taped a scene for the
ultra-innocent family sitcom while completely
stoned.
To be fair, he was a young dude in California
in the early '70s, and he thought he had the
day off.
But then he got a call from the producers,
who needed him on set that day after all.
Oops!
"Far out!"
Somehow nobody associated with The Brady Bunch
thought it was weird that Williams tripped
over his bike pump, awkwardly waved, slurred
his words, or looked the wrong way when his
onscreen little sister arrived on scene, all
with a dopey grin on his face.
Or maybe a secret hero knew what was up, and
decided to leave it in as a gift to future
generations?
Mystery Science Theater 3000
This cult classic follows the interstellar
travails of a poor sap imprisoned on a spaceship
with a crew of robots, mocking the low-budget
movies they're forced to watch.
Many of the films are riddled with mistakes—so
it's ironic that MST3K had its own spectacular
blooper make it into the finished product.
Inspired by a weapon in a terrible movie called
Danger!!
Death Ray, Tom Servo made his own death ray
and fired it at Crow.
That was all supposed to happen.
"I've gotta admit, it is pretty funny!"
The Crow puppet, however, wasn't supposed
to catch fire.
It was just the sort of anarchic silliness
that made Mystery Science Theater 3000 so
special…so the take was used.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!